hey guys heat here alright this is gonna
be my Game of Thrones Season seven
episode 7 the season finale recap
basically just gonna do a breakdown here
I got to tell you up front though that I
enjoyed this I think they actually
landed the plane there was definitely
some worries that I had and a lot of
people had been whining throughout the
season about details and different
things and if you're in that boat then
you're probably not going to be this
video is probably not gonna be for you
because I'm gonna talk about what was
good about this and I'm gonna be a fan
because tonight when I watch this I was
exactly that it's also a spoiler warning
here obviously if you haven't watched it
you're not going to want to watch this
video because it will spoil it so this
is the longest episode of Game of
Thrones ever it didn't necessarily feel
like that but the one thing that I said
just a moment ago was I think they
landed the plane and the way this all
kind of worked in my head at the end was
that I was engaged throughout there was
some pleasant surprises even though this
thing had been spoiled a million times
over by the leak and we got to the place
where we knew we were headed and we've
always known we've been headed and this
really opens up something new so as a
fan I'm excited because we don't know
what's gonna happen now we just really
don't I mean the White Walkers have
breached the wall they're moving south
it's freaking exciting and we did lose
stuff this season don't get me wrong we
lost some of the character development
we lost to travel we lost a lot of
things and things move too fast I
complained about that plenty but here we
are and this is an example of the show
doing what the show does well so let's
get through it and let's see where we're
at at the end so the big thing that I
had been waited for was this massive
meeting of all the characters in the
show basically at the dragon pit for
those of us that watch the filming
spoilers pretty closely in the off
season we knew this was going to go down
and it was unprecedented and then people
who were there and it was just done well
I mean I think that their idea of using
this structure a thing we've never seen
on the TV show before was a good choice
because it put everybody even though we
were
in King's Landing and there was
definitely a home-field advantage it
didn't feel like that and one of those
things that the show does well is that
it always makes you feel like anyone
could die at any time and I was just
kind of convinced that someone was gonna
randomly get killed during the scene
because it was just setup well that way
at the same time however though they
were you know kind of felt like they
might work this out I mean most of us
didn't trust anything that Cersei might
say but it was a pretty convincing
display whenever they actually presented
the white I mean the thing charged at
her The Hound cuts it in half it doesn't
die even a little bit it was awesome
Qyburn like was my favorite part of this
cuz he was just sort of like whoa look
at that that thing is still that fingers
are still moving and everyone that was
there understood that the threat from
the north is real there's this a lot of
cool moments here even the lead-up to
ever some awesome reunions you know
meeting in Tyrion with pod and Brienne
with the Hound and then Tyrion with
Bronn I mean this is this is good stuff
this is the stuff that we've been
waiting for right and you're on calling
out Theon and that everyone was kind of
like leaving their mark on this historic
event in one way or another
Euron gets up and leaves after the
display Cersei agrees to this but then
she adds on top those who only do it if
John agrees to stay out from now on like
he won't fight against her and that sort
of he gets the bomb of truth from John
that he's already bent the knee to
Daenerys which didn't go over very well
with anyone because no one was expecting
it all of that said at the end we find
out it's all fake anyways because the
Euron leaving was set up and Cersei
never even after the whole thing of
meeting with Tyrion and everything else
she never at any moment was gonna go
along with it like if you think about
that scene closely whenever she was
giving up the towel of being pregnant
she didn't drink the wine then she
touches her stomach it seemed odd but
it's not odd because she was doing that
like she played Tyrion in that scene so
all of what we saw the whole thing
Daenerys has grand entrance all that was
for
because Circe was never gonna get on
board her plan is instead to let
everybody else go and slaughter whatever
White Walkers they can and whatever's
left of either side the crown will take
them on because that'll be easier now
Jaime who is at this point the only
person she has left can't even go along
with her plan like he can't even believe
it and there is a real moment here
between these two because they both
understand what a terrible idea is to do
what she's going to do but where he says
he can't do it on the other side she
can't not do it so that's really pretty
[ __ ] fantastic as far as I'm
concerned like it was really it was hard
to watch him leave I believe that she
thought about killing him although she
didn't it was like you know it was it
was definitely set up well so in the end
he goes off in the north and we see the
snow start to come down and it's a
really great scene where we see all of
the you know different shots of King's
Landing with snow falling and then we go
up to the north and I want to point out
that whenever her and Tyrion had that
conversation
I mean Lena Headey pretty much owned the
whole first half of this episode I mean
she plays the despicable character that
you can't help but be compelled by so
well not to take away anything from
Tyrion or Jaime I mean those their
acting was fantastic too but this was
really like a tour de force for the
whole Cersei character I think because
like I said she's completely despicable
and what she does but you kind of can't
help but be compelled by the character
and it's not just like on an evil like I
hate this character it's sort of like
well I kind of see how she got to that
place not that it's excusable or
anything else but it's just I don't know
what other word to use besides
compelling like I just like to watch her
act
also the Brienne thing was fantastic
whenever she pulls Jaime up this is the
person who has the biggest connection to
loyalty and keeping OHS and things like
that and she's the one that has to throw
it back on Jaime like this is crazy we
can't do this so you had these two
characters twins lovers the whole nine
yards and Jamie finally has to break
from her
head north there we see that Santa's
still talking to Littlefinger and it
really starts to put some fear into me
personally but then we see how it all
plays out and I don't know I mean I
don't think that i think that this ended
well
I don't think that it makes up for some
of the awkwardness and the other Stark's
sister parts before this but it ended
well we find out that they were working
together we see that it's not aria
that's in trouble whenever they call it
it's actually Littlefinger who they're
trying for treason and murder and I have
to say I got a new I mean obviously
little fingers always been an awesome
character but I got a new respect for
Sansa as a character because we see how
he/she did pick up all the stuff from
him and while he's doing his thing she
just rebuts each one perfectly and it
was a trip to see when they first
brought Aria in and we see the
full-grown Sansa and the full grown
brand sitting at the table and their
family's Great Hall it was pretty good
and aria was a little bit ruthless and
that's why she should be but I think
that that all got kind of better
whenever they had that personal moment
later like that was the one thing I was
sort of like okay well of course he has
to die of course this should go down
this way but I hope they don't keep Aria
in this strange world of like being only
an assassin because she's a character
that has a lot of depth you know she's
had a lot of things and can bring a lot
to the story and so whenever I saw the
two sisters together later that really
worked things out I would say but yeah I
mean sauce it did a great job here and
the one of the things I read earlier it
kind of cracked me up was that as he was
dying Littlefinger it looked like a
robot that was breaking down or
something along those lines you know he
was just sort of bouncing around he's
never been in this place and he's just
bouncing around from one thing to the
other to try to get his way to get
himself out of trouble and sonses there
and she doesn't bend she has her family
there backing her up and it was pretty
good let's let's be honest that was
pretty good
I think it came off well and the story
will miss Littlefinger
but you could see that we're moving into
a different phase and and the skills he
had and what he brought to this story is
pretty much unimportant at this point
you know what I mean like he was good at
playing the game of Thrones and we heard
some sub-points us out as the whole
things going down that really doesn't
matter anymore the White Walkers are
coming and they're gonna kill everyone
regardless of anything else doesn't
matter
and so his character really isn't
essential to anything else moving
forward because politics are kind of out
the window at this point so we do also
get a real big dose of the wolf and the
dragon or the dragon and the wolf I
should say Ice and Fire come together
not just dant Dany and John as samurai
they have this great back-and-forth with
bran which also kind of saved brands I
think I mean I don't know what you guys
think but I thought that bran was way
more human here his deadpan was funny
instead of just creepy
you know when he said I remember
everything about Sam and whenever Sam
said you know did you see that in the
flames like he was all giddy because he
thought he could see this that John was
coming and he just sort of shows him the
the scroll that they received you know
what I mean like I don't know if it was
just this director did a better job than
the other directors did or what but this
worked we got to make our Lyanna
flashback which wasn't a big surprise to
anyone at this point we had already
heard that they were married it was cool
to see it was a little bit awkward that
they showed it as Daenerys and John were
having sex for the first time it was the
weird juxtaposition of like you know
something that we all like people who
have been reading the books and watching
the shows and really been into this
whole lore of everything about the Song
of Ice and Fire you know what I mean
this was sort of like a it was sort of
odd how they put these two things
together but after the fact I was
thinking you know it is the Song of Ice
and Fire we see those two coming
together to the the union that brought
John into the world and then we see John
as a grown man and he's with his aunt I
know it's weird but I don't know I it'll
be interesting to see how they go beyond
that I would have liked to seen a little
bit more of Rhaegar and Lyanna it was
pretty short but it was what it was it
was Brandon basically explained it to
people who might not know the story
Samwell was there to fill in the blanks
about the annulment and now we know that
John is legitimately the best claim out
of the Targaryen line and that together
they are the last Targaryen not that
Daenerys is the only Targaryen left so
yeah I mean I think it's messed up as it
all fell it's about prophecy it's about
this idea it's a you know even at the
underlying one of the most poignant
moments of the whole flashback is when
brand says Robert's rebellion was about
a lie and that's true but beyond that
everything Rhaegar did that led to that
was based off a prophecy and I think
that that is almost as important as
anything else that we saw here and yeah
it's hard to imagine not thinking about
the fact that they're doing what they're
doing but you know what I mean I think
it does actually work and if nothing
else that'll have people talking that's
for sure and then the big exclamation
point on the end of the sentence is
obviously seeing tormund and Barrack on
top of the wall and watching the White
Walkers come I had concerns about this I
was worried that if they just used the
dragon it might not make sense but it
kind of does now I mean I think it
worked
part of it is out of convenience I would
say in that I think that in georgia's
you know George RR Martin's
version will get your on playing a big
part and maybe some other characters
playing a big part in this whereas all
of it just sort of got condensed down to
where the knight King does it himself so
I think it's I'm ok with it I'll talk
about a little bit more but it was
really fantastic to watch I mean you
can't you can't be a fan of Game of
Thrones and say that that was not an
impressive amount of I mean we never saw
anything like that on TV before ever
before the show came into existence so
if you're like well it was okay then
you're probably just spoiled and you
forget what TV was like before this
happened to be honest and you're just
looking for
to be salty because that's just what you
do I don't know because it was amazing
and yeah I mean the the season went all
over the place it wasn't clear if it was
gonna wrap up correctly or in a
satisfying way but it definitely did I
have no doubt people will complain about
things because that's what people do but
this story has always been about that
wall coming down and the Ted cut mean
it's the winners coming is the house
dark words and what we saw in this
episode was that without a doubt winner
is here it's hard to say how things are
gonna move forward but all the pieces
are in place I think what really is
interesting is what I was talking about
before like about when I'm talking about
little fingers death I mean all this
stuff that has been important the
political moves the strategy on the
different players in the game it's all
done now now it really is a fight for
survival and not just a survival of one
house or the other but of mankind and
that's what this has always been set up
to be and we did lose things in this
season we lost a lot based on the fact
of the magical spectacle that is
necessary to show that and you know
you're not gonna have anything be
perfect but I think this actually worked
and I think that it's cool and the thing
that I thought about what the dragon was
is that you know the leaks kind of
killed all of that instead of thinking
about it and being surprised in the
moment while watching people sort of
form that idea I know I did like I
thought that that was just [ __ ] and
it wasn't gonna happen and saying I just
refused to believe that the leaks were
real for a very long time but when you
see it in the context of how it was used
like that isn't a dragon anymore that's
not Daenerys his dragon that died that
the knight King now has control over
that is an extension of the knight Kings
power whenever he raised Vissarion back
up that became a part of this wave of
Terror that's coming into Westeros and
in that context that works for me and
I'll be interested to see what you guys
think some of my favorite parts were
those reunions it was just fantastic
like I said they acting
top-notch the dialogue was good I you
know I mean I just don't have anything I
dislike about this episode so make sure
you let me know what you think and if
you're like I said if you're just like
gonna say stuff about details and other
things I mean this story has changed
into something else but what I'm so
excited about as a fan of the show is
seeing how this develops towards the end
and if you want to find things to be
wrong you'll always be able to find them
but we're at a pretty good pretty good
point to be a fan of this show so make
sure you like the video if you enjoyed
it make sure you subscribe to my channel
if you haven't already make sure you
turn on notifications I'll be making G
ot videos all through the year so keep
an eye out for those like my facebook
page and follow me on twitter and all
those other things we can interact over
there thanks for watching guys I'll talk
to you soon